salut vidéo numéro 13 sur 32 de cette
petite série de l'été sur le fait de
donner une énigme par jour tous les
jours je vous donne une énigme et je
vous donne la réponse à l'énigme de la
veille donc si vous n'avez pas vu
l'énigme d'hier allait la regarder
puisque là je vais donner la réponse est
la réponse à tient en un seul mot
attention la solution à l'énigme d'hier
était le silence le silence qu'on
prononce son nom on le brise est
forcément y meurt c'est la chose la plus
fragile du monde le silence mais vous
vous n'êtes pas fragile et c'est pour ça
que vous allez tenter l'énigme
d'aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression d'être
thibault in shape
vous êtes les meilleurs énigme 13 avec
accessoires j'avoue dessiner un oeuf en
chiffres romains et voici l'énigme en
rajoutant un seul trait vous devez
transformer ce 9 ans 6 allée d'un seul
trait sans rien effacé vous devez
transformer ce 9 ans 6 comme d'habitude
si vous avez la bonne réponse ne la
mettez pas dans les commentaires mais tu
es simplement j'ai trouvé et mettez un
pouce en l'air pour nous faire
comprendre que vous avez trouvé la
réponse passé un bel été pensez à vous
abonner avant de partir puisque le
mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an
rendez vous demain à 17h ciao